let's hear from some people in the
audience we take calls via Discord at
davidpackman.com Discord
um make sure that you uh set your
nickname in the waiting Lobby to your
name and where you're calling from those
are the rules nicknames Etc are not
welcome let's go first to Tyrone from
Ohio Tyrone welcome what's on your mind
today
Tyrone welcome what is on your mind
today my friend you got to set your
audio device to the appropriate one
and Tyrone Last Chance what is going on
my friend what's on your mind today
hello can you hear me yes now I can hear
you Tyrone what's going on
okay so like things in Ohio they're
getting real bad in here and I'm
wondering like the dentist when what you
think is next
what is the gameplay
if DeSantis becomes president of the
United States you're saying
yes
well that was we're skipping ahead I
mean first he's got to become the
nominee you know your question depends
on what exactly is happening in January
of 2025 when a hypothetical DeSantis
presidency would start like what's on
your mind what specifically is getting
bad in Ohio that you're worried about
oh I mean just the name itself it's
already kind of bad but um you know just
like a
it seems like dystopian future would be
most ideal if uh distances became
president
I'm just wondering like what's the
direction of the country if he does well
it's going to continue in this sort of
like modern I think what we're calling
it is reactionary populist uh Direction
and it's not going to be about policy
it's not going to be about helping
people it's not going to be about
improving the country it's going to be
about culture War issues and reactionary
populism and some authoritarianism
sprinkled in and unfortunately DeSantis
is arguably more dangerous than Trump
because he's less incompetent but let's
you know let's first deal with the
primaries I would say just to not get
ahead of ourselves and we've got local
elections coming up in 2023 so there's
still a lot of work to do before we get
to that let's let Republicans have their
primary first then we'll worry about
DeSantis
Tyrone all right Tyrone thank you very
much for the call an important question
let's face it the holiday season can be
a stressful time for anyone even a
stressor on relationships in-laws
dividing time mismatched expectations
around gifts our sponsor paired is the
app that makes it easy to maintain a
feeling of connection with your partner
during this crazy time of year you and
your partner download the app you pair
together an everyday paired gives the
two of you questions or quizzes games to
have fun stay emotionally connected
deepen your conversations and all of the
exercises were developed by academic
psychologists and expert relationship
therapists as well my girlfriend and I
have been using paired quite a bit
lately it's fun especially with the baby
these days it's more important than ever
for us to find quality time and parrot
is really the perfect way to spark that
with funny moments meaningful
conversations and we can use paired on
the go don't let end of year stressors
get in the way of you and your partner
enjoying some connecting paired makes it
simple and giving your significant other
a paired subscription is a great last
minute holiday gift head over to
paired.com Pacman for a seven day free
trial and 25 off a subscription the link
is down below